[Music]
red sox starter it just feels different
when he's on the mound at fenway park it
does i mean it starts with the
confidence you know the guys play well
behind him getting the run support and
that's exactly what they need tonight
here's a 2-2
struck him out with a nasty change-up
rev snyder down hacking excellent change
up good arm speed right there and some
slight fade on that pitch to have roof
reps not out front on it
number one for chris sale so donaldson
to step up 250 19 home runs he's home in
the first two games of the series
sale gets him
he strikes him out second k for the
lefty
all right that was a nice fastball up in
his own on the outer half
could not get to it i'm particularly
interested in how john gant does tonight
twins have some openings in their
starting rotation gant making his second
start on this road trip 33 games pitch
for number 33
good breaking ball
and we've seen martinez swing and miss
and a lot of sliders two down and
that'll bring up devor he must have been
watching griffin jack's pitch the other
night is kind of what he did to him in
his first played appearance executed
that slider down
in the zone
red sox don't score six batters face
three walks and now christian arroyo
will battle
ground ball simmons gets the force at
third hasta dio
with a nice scoop on a low throw and may
have gotten spiked but simmons got the
out at the only base probably he could
have gotten an out at yeah just great
instinctual play recognizing you're not
gonna be able to turn two and also give
credit to the deal
of being in the right spot a guy who
hasn't
i can't
think of in recent memory the last time
he's actually been out there at third
base to start a game so he's out there
he's in the right position and got
spiked on the way by but they get the
lead runner and keep the double play in
order nice play by simmons nice job by
sedillo vasquez advancing brings up
bobby dalbeck 229 14 home runs nothing
nothing game
1-0 there goes duran swinging a high fly
ball deep left center carrying carry and
gone
hello
you got to give me that call
excellent
i think you called it yes sir
and the red sox lead it three to nothing
on number 15 from bobby dalbeck a
fastball on the inner half he unloaded
on it right there
full extension
souvenir city
in the stands
first hit for the red sox bobby
dalbeck's had an excellent month of
august sox in front three nothing an
immaculate inning for chris sale one two
three they go chris sale strikes out the
side on nine pitches that was quick and
you never see that hardly very rare
yeah advance schwarber down to third and
two away so up to alex ferdugo to get it
done
and a live shot base hit that'll get it
done
roduko continues to pick on minnesota
back to first base in rbi
yes he does
nice solid opposite field hit just like
i was saying this guy can hit the ball
all over the park
and he just flicks this split finger
a little off speed pitch and just goes
with it didn't try to do too much with
it nice sharp single to left with an rbi
rise came closest to hitting a wicked
100 on the first base line of bobby
dalbeck
one hopper what a play arroyo
[Music]
he stole a hit
let me tell you this guy's making
defensive plays at second base like it's
nothing just a sharp one hopper right to
him with the scoop nice easy turn
excellent play we'll see what ostidio
can do here with one down
drill to left and the twins are on the
board hasta deal cranks one a two run
home run cutting the boston lead in half
well jeffers took care of the no-hitter
and
custodial took care of the shutout nice
swing right here
this was a bomb this thing
105 miles an hour off the bat after
jeffers hit the ball 40 miles an hour so
two runs and as you said this thing just
got a lot closer
slider that kind of stayed up that
didn't have that downward movement that
we've seen
from the good ones that he's throwing in
this game and off the deal knew it
immediately
raphael tonight missed flight out
grounded out over two
jumped on that one he scolds it into
right
here comes hernandez the throw will be
cut played at third we'll get him
92 runs batted in for rafael devers red
sox run top 5-2
there we go get back on the board there
he takes this pitch and shoots a bullet
to right field scoring [ __ ] from second
base fastball right on the inner half
and just shoots it right to red field
[ __ ] scores easily and going first first
and thirds kyle schwarber with an
excellent lead so 80 pitches for chris
sale that is a season high he matches
his first start against baltimore
when he struck out eight
and here he comes off the hill tonight
at fenway park
to a nice applause and a 5-2 lead so the
twins will bring in the defense a couple
of steps here with a count of 1-0 on
dalbeck nobody out
that's going to be down for a base hit
that'll bring in two
arroyo scores and duran right behind him
bobby dulbeck with a five rbi game and
the red sox open it up seven to two and
that's getting the head of that bat out
in front shooting this bullet it's a
fastball right down the middle he got
the head out shot a bullet to center
field and i'll tell you what the key to
this
jared durant got a great jump look at
this he just took off knowing that ball
was going to drop in center field but
base hit and all that with two rbis
right there the bases are loaded one and
one
simmons with a nice catch out there and
a double play
a magnificent double play started by
anderson simmons well that's one of the
better ones you'll see terrific getting
to this ball and making a good feed
good strong throw to first but another
run in it's eight to two red sox and
here's raphael devers raphael swings
it's a long drive out to right field
that snyder back back
rafael never strikes a wicked live drive
number 30.
that's the second time in his career
he has reached 30 home runs
he's driven in three tonight so his 94
runs batted in and that smile shows it
all a flat fastball down and in and he
just dropped the head on it
nice balance right there with that swing
he knows he got it at least off the wall
but it was in the pin special to get to
30. bobby's home run in second inning
drove in three is single in the sixth
inning drove in two
here's a drive but tied to the wall and
that ball is gone
bobby d have yourself a knight
wow his second home run this is a
two-run shot
he's driven in seven
what an evening for bobby dalbeck
that is outstanding
to have a night like that i'll tell you
[Music]
look like a split finger he got out in
front and it was a line drive i was i
was afraid for the fans up there yeah
oh
that's a night the red sox have added on
in a big way dolbeck a sensational ball
game red sox on top 12-2 two out on the
top of the ninth
in there strike three with a curveball
landed red sox win it 12-2
bobby dalbeck the hitting star as he
drove in seven a career-high with two
home runs